rassemblement suivi par nos reporters
est elle chargée lucas léger lucas léger
qu'on retrouve tout de suite lucas
bonjour alors vous suivez pour nous la
manifestation qui est parti en lion à
deux ans maintenant de place de la
bastille se rappelle des gilet jaune
quelle est l'ambiance actuellement
et bien un miracle tout un épisode des
tirs de projectiles et des tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes par les forces de l'ordre
et les manifestants donc ont tiré des
projectiles
désormais la situation semble plus calme
vous pouvez voir derrière moi que le
cortège jeu suit son cours dans les rues
du 8e arrondissement je vous propose
d'écouter la version de faouzi lellouche
gilet jaune qui était sur la
manifestation qui m'a raconté comment
s'est passée cette altercation avec les
forces de l'ordre selon lui le cortège
de gendarmerie nous a bloqués nous a
chargés dans une petite rue et du coup
on n'a pas eu le choix que de reculer et
de partir sur la gauche ou la droite
tellement et casey est tellement il
donnait des coups de sa pleuvait de deux
coups de matraque tonfa
donc on est arrivé sur la gauche on a
voulu rejoindre le cortège devant et on
a trouvé au moins 50 policiers motorisés
donc de la brave qui est qu'ils ont
commencé à faire un cortège et on leur a
expliqué qu'on n'avait pas eu le choix
d'aller à gauche pour sauver les gens
tellement sa charge un de ce côté là du
coup on a essayé de rattraper le cortège
part oh et puis a du coup nous ont
repoussés jusqu'à la voilà mais c'est
pas de la faute des gens c'est pas la
faute des manifestants pourquoi bloquer
ces milliers de personnes qui alla qui
manifestent pour lentilles pour
lentilles pas sanitaire pas je sais pas
pourquoi
à croire que ça les arrange cueillait
que y ait de la casse alors qu'avec des
gens pacifiques ici
avant cet épisode est bien la
manifestation se déroulait selon une
ambiance bon enfant je vous propose
d'écouter quelques manifestants que j'ai
pu interroger au début de cette
manifestation des personnes qui
s'opposent bien sûr à l'extension du
pass sanitaire annoncé par une part un
manuel macro le 12 juillet la
vaccination à chacun doit avoir le droit
de le faire ou pas
c'est pas le problème mais le problème
c'est que ils veulent la met une
ségrégation parmi la population
en fait c'est juste un passage c'est
pour nous diviser et ensuite le passé ni
terre ce sera pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui depuis la location du
président à public le 12 juillet c'est
un tournant de notre histoire
des gens se sont battus pour la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
aujourd'hui c'est président a tout remis
en cause aujourd'hui on en posant
passani car les gens sont libres de
choisir de se faire vacciner n'est pas
imposé un passé ni d'air progressivement
on va se retrouver dans une dictature
pure et dure comme en corée du nord à
dose homéopathique sans qu'on s'en
aperçoive
là ils veulent nous obliger à nous
vacciner il commence par certains
fonctionnaires soient des gens qui sont
au fond de tableau contact mais ça va
finir par toute la population
ces manifestants ils ne misent pas sur
les institutions pour retirer cette loi
est mise plutôt sur la pression de la
rue pour faire plier le gouvernement il
y avait eu selon le ministère de
l'intérieur
114 mille personnes dans les rues contre
le pass sanitaire la semaine dernière
mais selon ces manifestants et bien la
mobilisation est beaucoup plus
importante